well do you have a teenager around the
house who's always reciting lines for
movies or
maybe your tween is creating dance
routines with uh songs on the radio
well we've got a camp just for them
bianca holman continues our summer fun
series this morning bianca you got to
tell us about how they can get their
thespian on at this camp i'm not going
to lie when i was a kid
i used to perform for my grandparents
all the time it's got to be a place for
somebody to let all that out right
definitely for sure sherry and sherry
i'm gonna tell you like aunt deb told me
she said
if you want to make it big you want fame
will fame
cost and you start pay for it and sweat
right
here did i get that right bernard you
got that right and we do a lot of
sweating
exactly well bernard gaddis is the
executive director of the contemporary
west dance theater so tell us about this
intensive program that you all have this
summer
well actually the contemporary west
dance theater actually has been
around for 15 years we're celebrating 15
years and we're the very first
professional contemporary dance theater
to be in las vegas
and so of course by for us wanting to
train kids in the community and actually
all over we have a summer intensive
program
that starts july 12th through the 30th
yeah so tell us they
not everybody can just walk in off the
street and get into this intensive
program so
is there a tryout or submission process
that is correct actually we've had
auditions
throughout the year this past year one
being a large
large audition with the iabd
organization international association
of blacks and dance
but we actually auditioned from all over
but this year because of covet and
because of the pandemic
we've been doing submissions so we still
have submissions available people can
submit or
you know contact us even in the city and
come on down and join us for the summer
all right so i mean i heard some
people's hearts drop a little bit but
that you can still
submit okay so their doors are still
open there's still some spots left
give us a little bit more detail is
there a cost associated
yes there is a cost we try to keep the
cost low
again doing because of the covet and the
pandemic so we will be
dropping the cost so it's affordable for
families and
you can actually look at look that up at
our website at www.lvdance.org
all right wonderful he's going to teach
me an eight count again this is a
veteran here he just retired can i say
that
yes you do okay well congratulations
you know some people don't want to say
but again we say congratulations to him
he's a professional dancer been doing it
for several several years so again great
programming for everybody out there and
again we'll have
more details about all the performing
arts again dance
acting they're doing it all here in the
city of las vegas back to you guys in
the studio